well welcome back to Oracle Arena where
Sonia and Dell curry gets a watch and be
the proud parents of the first pair of
brothers to play this late in an NBA
playoff environment Dell you carved out
a 16-year career yourself so you
understand the achievement of getting
here but for parents to watch two young
men who've always competed against each
other compete in this level
what are your days like can you eat can
you sleep are you nervous what's it like
no Doris we thought it would be a lot of
fun it's not so much fun
leading up to the first game about a
couple hours before the game it was
really hard getting ready getting
ourselves prepared for not being all in
for one one child you got to keep it
neutral so it's really tougher than we
thought you have one son Steph was a
two-time MVP multiple time champion you
yourself know how difficult that is just
a car about any kind of NBA career Seth
seems to have to live with some
comparisons as somebody who's been
through that rigor what have you told
your young son just to relax again this
is the first time through with Seth
being in the playoffs and the pressure
playing in the conference finals it's a
first for him I thought he had a little
jitters the first game just to relax be
himself come in try to change the game
but knock down some shots hopefully he
gets that person to go in and leave them
up a little bit our nature as parents
and particularly moms so I'm going to
ask you to speak a little bit for Sonia
so I don't have to lean across I think
most mothers would bristle and the
notions in anyway our children are less
than perfect your kids are being
evaluated daily and under great scrutiny
what's it like for Sonia as a mom to
have to listen to some of that it's way
more stressful for her
myself I've been through it before she
does a good job of not really paying
attention to everything that that's
being said but it's hard for it like you
said she wants to be perfect
she hates any kind of negativity that
comes their way but she understands this
part of the game part of me is there any
room for fun here
no not at all she's very stressed she
doing with only has a cocktail before
the game no cocktail tonight that's how
stress she is I know I like Sonja
cocktail speaking my language thank you
so much
and the family what an emotional roller
coasters must be for them meanwhile just
under 53 seconds remaining and again
brother on brother cried for another
three
and the quick hands
late
is riding that Portland wave right now